solar power has made great strides over
the past several years
but to this day it's really not
practical
on a large scale currently the average
solar panel
is able to produce up to 850 kilowatt
hours per month
per 400 square feet this doesn't sound
too bad
until you realize that we consume 22.3
trillion kilowatts of electricity every
single year
meaning that if we were to rely on solar
today we would have to cover
876 billion
square feet with solar cells clearly
that's not viable today but here's how
tesla
is rapidly rewriting the fate of solar
[Music]
well starting off tesla is making solar
power
more accessible to the average person
tesla solar panels can be bought
outright financed or most importantly
rented renting solar panels is only
available in a couple of states right
now
but this is likely the most attractive
solution to the average person
tesla covers the installation and
maintenance cost of the panels
and you'd only be paying the monthly
subscription cost which starts at 50
per month you will however have to
purchase a tesla power wall
which does cost several thousand dollars
but
nonetheless this does still wipe out the
thirty to forty thousand dollars
that the solar panels would have run you
so
it is still much more accessible than
paying for full solar installation
outright on top of this the best part
about tesla solar renting model
is that there is no cancellation fee if
you cancel
they'll simply turn off your unit the
only time you'll be running into
cancellation costs
is if you actually want them to remove
the solar panels from your house
which would cost you 2 500
aside from being much more accessible
tesla's offerings are generally more
than sufficient for the average u.s
household
and this is saying something as we all
know
that u.s households are power consumers
the average u.s household consumes 877
kilowatt hours of electricity
per month tesla's top offering produces
up to 59 kilowatt hours per day so
the average person should have no
problem completely relying on solar
power
from an electricity perspective
additionally
tesla solar panels are quite efficient
as well
with an efficiency rating of 19.6
percent
and tesla solar panels hold up pretty
well against heat
with a temperature coefficient of 0.39
percent
which means that the panel's efficiency
is only reduced by 0.39 percent
for every degree celsius above 25.
though this is great and all this is
really not the big deal
as there are plenty of competitors who
have solar panels that are just as
powerful
and efficient if not more the real area
in which tesla is innovating
is with your power wall you see at this
point in time
generating power using solar panels is
not the biggest concern
the real issue when it comes to solar
energy is of course
reliability obviously solar panels need
light in order to work
and they will not work at night nor when
the sun is blocked or obscured by clouds
or the moon or something else as a
result
storing excess energy produced by solar
panels when they are generating
electricity
is just as important as actually
generating sufficient energy
in the first place the tesla power wall
is able to store
up to 13.5 kilowatt hours each two of
these would be capable of running the
average u.s household for a full
24 hours on their own anyways
moving on we have cost savings for
commercial customers
after all the industrial sector accounts
for 32
of all u.s energy consumption the
average manufacturing facility consumes
95.1 kilowatt hours of electricity
per square foot per year considering
that we are talking about tesla
let's use one of their gigafactories as
an example
tesla's upcoming gigafactory in texas
covers a massive
2 000 acres assuming that only 10
percent of this will become operational
space
we have 8.7 million square feet of
factory space
which would indicate that tesla would
need approximately 827
million kilowatt hours of electricity
every year or about
2.3 million kilowatt hours per day
tesla's largest solar panels cover 960
square feet
and produce 40 to 60 kilowatt hours per
day we'll call it
50 kilowatt hours per day elon musk has
always dreamed about covering the entire
roof of gigafactories with solar panels
but they have never actually done this
before so
we'll say that they'll only end up
covering half of the operational space
with solar panels
which can accommodate for 4 500 extra
large solar panels
together these will generate 225 000
kilowatt hours per day
or a respectable 10 of the entire
factory's power needs
these 4 500 solar panels however will
cost an eye watering
150 million in this scenario
there is no need for power walls as the
factory consumes more energy
than the solar panels produce meaning
that there will be no need
to actually store any energy the average
electricity rate in the u.s
is 13.19 per kilowatt hour
but we'll assume that large consumers
pay less than this
at about 10 cents per kilowatt hour this
indicates that the solar panels will be
saving the tesla gigafactory
22 500 in electricity costs every single
day
at this rate the solar panels will pay
for themselves in just 18.26 years
or within 20 years considering that
tesla provides a 25-year warranty with
their solar panels
and that tesla's warranty claims that
their solar panels will still be at
least 80
as productive in 25 years 20 years is
well within the lifespan of their solar
panels
and everything after 20 years is pure
profit
which is big savings when we're looking
at commercial customers
for instance if tesla continues to use
the solar panels for another 10 years
and if the solar panels are about 75 as
productive
as they were at the start we would be
looking at approximately
2.15 billion kilowatt hours of
electricity production
throughout those three decades what's an
investment of 150 million
we'd be looking at just under 7 cents
per kilowatt hour
that's a 30 reduction in electricity
costs
even if they were previously paying just
10 cents per kilowatt hour
if they were paying the national average
of 13.19
that comes out to a massive 47 reduction
in price
in fact in our example switching to
solar would have saved tesla
65 million dollars in electricity costs
and though that was just an example this
is precisely what's happening in 2017
tesla installed a 100 megawatt system in
south australia
which is estimated to have saved a
whopping 40 million dollars in just the
first year
considering this at this point solar is
becoming reliably cheaper than regular
electricity
over the long term thus it's starting to
make sense for commercial customers
as well anyways the next major advantage
tesla's offering in the solar space
is their massive funding power tesla is
by far
the largest player in the solar space
worth upwards of 400 billion dollars
mostly due to their ev and autonomy
business
but nonetheless they are the largest
player
and this provides them with insane
funding power
most businesses lose money for many
years and sometimes even decades
when they are growing and expanding
their customer base and their products
this is especially true when it comes to
disruptive technology
however given tesla's success in the eva
business
which doesn't seem to be slowing down
anytime soon
this gives them great flexibility when
it comes to running their solar business
in other words they can afford to lose
hundreds of millions of dollars
or even billions of dollars in their
solar business and not be concerned with
bankruptcy
and this is extremely common when
companies try to convince a very broad
audience
to try something new for instance
amazon's retail business
was unprofitable up until 2018 as
amazon was convincing people to shop
online and get amazon prime
however they were able to sustain
decades of losses
using their other business amazon web
services
there are many such examples within the
business world but the biggest example
by far
is of course google nearly everything
google does
is a money losing project their entire
business model
consists of providing a bunch of money
losing services for free
in an attempt to lure people into the
google ecosystem
at which point they profit from people
using google.com
this is even the case with youtube even
though they pull in billions of dollars
in ad revenue every year
their infrastructure cost is even more
this may have changed recently
but nonetheless this was the case for
the vast majority of youtube's lifetime
anyways the reason i bring this up is to
showcase that getting tens of millions
of people
to adopt a new technology or service
often requires a money losing
proposition
for the business this is because the
average consumer
generally needs a no-brainer proposition
in order for them to adopt a new service
slash product free mail services cloud
services
map services and streaming services are
a no-brainer
and consequently google has attracted
the masses
paying 50k up front and saving on your
electricity bill over 30 years however
is not that appealing on the other hand
a renting service which may also cover
the power wall in the future
is very attractive when converting the
masses to solar
the only issue with going on such a
venture is that it will take
decades for such a model to even become
net positive
but it seems like tesla is not only
ready for such a journey
but more importantly they are also
financially capable
of handling such adventure without
facing a constant threat
of death thus at the end of the day
solar energy is cheaper than regular
electricity over the long term
and this advantage will likely only
widen as we move forward
however though many savvy businesses and
governments will
understand and value the long-term cost
savings of solar
this is unlikely to be as clear to the
average customer
who require low cost of entry and
reliability to make the jump
fortunately tesla solar renting model
along with their power walls
may be exactly what the average consumer
is looking for
and what tesla needs to grow their solar
business to become larger than their ev
business
propelling our future into clean energy
what do you guys think about tesla's
renting model
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys are excited for an eventual
solar future and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys on the next one